Good morning, John.
You may have noticed several videos in a row, there's this big...
empty ar- do you know why that is?
It's because over here...
I was making a video for Wizard School, and I- that was my tripod.
Ten years, John.
You'd think I'd have bought a second tripod.
There it is.
That's better.
So John, I think it is important
for...
us to talk about the things that we disagree with our old selves about.
So I wanted to talk about this train that I used to be on.
Called the Machiavellian Train.
I don't know why it's a train. I decided just now.
And the idea is that good people
have to be willing to do all the same stuff that bad people are willing to do in order to get a good outcome,
because otherwise the bad people are gonna do all their bad stuff,
and they're gonna get their bad thing done.
This was a very appealing idea to me as a younger man.
Partly, yes, because it allowed me to excuse me doing things that maybe weren't in consort with my values.
But I think it was mostly because it played into this thing that I wanted to believe about myself.
That if I could only use my brain enough, I could manipulate other people and the world,
to an eventual positive outcome.
Like I was the protagonist in a lot of the books that I liked.
Like, I was Ender Wiggin, or Frank Chalmers, or Paul Atreides
If you don't know what those things are, that's fine. We don't read the same kinds of books.
As I have gotten more...
power...
uh, you hear people in social media circles call this "influence,"
but let's call it what it is.
I have gotten way more wary, and even, sort of afraid of that perspective.
So I wanna give you some reasons why I think, like, the Machiavelli train
is made of B.S.
So first, healthy societies rely on trust.
And if we are all seeing each other as pawns,
that trust will never exist. And when I
saw people more as pawns to be moved to my will,
I was able to trust other people less, 'cause I thought they saw me that way too.
And that, among all the other bad stuff that comes with that, is just a bad feeling.
Second, you are never a hundred percent
that the thing you're trying to accomplish is actually gonna have a positive effect in the world.
There are lots of examples of people having big revolutions against really oppressive things,
and then it getting even worse afterward.
There are also examples of people having revolutions and the outcome being good.
But you never really know. So if you're headed along
to this eventual goal, and you're just destroying everything on the way there?
If this turns out not to have the intended effect,
then you've done a lot of bad stuff to get to a bad outcome.
Third, you gotta remember,
that there's a really high chance,
that you're not gonna get to the desired outcome.
You're never gonna get there. So you could do a whole bunch of bad stuff on the way to trying to get there,
and then fail. And that happens...
all the time!
And lastly, I have come to realize that this thing...
doesn't exist.
There is no final end goal. Every single decision along the path of your life
is an end in itself.
And if the entire world lived as if the ends justify the means,
then the means in themselves
are gonna be a terrifying end.
So I jumped off that train.
And now I do not see an idea as a good idea
if it requires me to defy my values or my ethics.
It doesn't matter how good it's gonna be in the end,
or what- all the stuff I could do with that money if I got it.
And I kinda needed to get okay with discarding ideas
because I couldn't figure out how to do them
and still be living the right way.
And that was surprisingly hard. Because I think, throughout my life,
I praised ideas above reality.
In a kind of way. I don't know if that made sense.
And I needed to get over that, and it's kind of been a liberation for me, because, one,
limitations are actually good for ideas. Like, being able to do
anything to get to your desired goal can be really paralyzing.
And two, it means that when I fail,
which I will do over and over and over again, and we all will do,
at least along the way to that failure, I did a bunch of things that I believed in.
And honestly, I've come to accept and believe
that it's those millions of tiny,
sometimes invisible actions, more than any huge accomplishment,
that really makes humanity work.
John, in the last ten years of doing this with you, and with this community,
this is one of the best...
and most helpful,
most important lessons I've learned.
Thank you for that.
Memento mori.
And I will see you in Bosto-